foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys we're extremely
careful and we were so careful just now
yeah just now yeah it wasn't recording
though it was so early what were we
being careful about Nick I'm doing I'm
doing the the BART face
okay so today's prompt is if
uh you were to redo College uh knowing
what you know today oh knowing what I
know today knowing what you know today
how would you redo it and yes you are
yes you aren't like 40 years old you're
a college age oh okay okay okay so it's
like a Lindsay Lohan movie where your
brain goes back to your old body did you
watch that movie no is that freaking I
watched the commercial I didn't know
that movie because people talk about it
did you watch that movie or brain
doesn't go in your old body yeah what
are you talking about how does It Go
video what's it called is that is that
right yeah that's where you switch
Friday switches with the mom yeah oh
anyway
for some reason parent traps completely
different yes yes totally different and
also is it that social climate or this
social club it's two days that's a good
question do we watch the same Parent
Trap because yeah it never leaves your
[ __ ] body of the parents right parent
traps it's just twins I think she just
schooled my ass yeah Joe keep going I
haven't watched is the world is the
world sentiment what it is today or was
it when we were it's just it's just what
we know today that's simplified what we
know today but then it's like all of a
sudden we're in college now redo it
again so it's like 2 000 and nobody
knows two thousand no he's saying 2022.
he says you wake up 2022 it's right now
it's right now you're in college but
that's what I'm saying just move on to
the [ __ ] dream God damn it right now
this is what happened what are the rules
all right what color shirt am I wearing
I guess I would have done College to
begin with really some good places you
really think you would want to do
college well in this mindset I guess
because
what would you study what would you
study what would I study yeah oh you
know what I actually would study is um
because you got to do entertainment so
that it's like present day Steve going
back I think programming would be fun
honestly that makes sense because it's
it's fascinating anyway I kind of Tinker
around with it like using crypto stuff
anyway so it'd be kind of fun now that
you're being practical I think I would
have learned some [ __ ] Finance or
some [ __ ] this just got cold extremely
fast well either that I [ __ ] quit
because [ __ ] college is useless but
if I were to learn something something
that's practical I could use with my
hands on like I was a bio major right
you can't do [ __ ] that's so cool I know
what a [ __ ] mother country is yeah I
can't do [ __ ] with that doctor because
that's the track you were going to gotta
go another four years of [ __ ] or you
could be a pet doctor like my sister and
want to kill yourself
she loves that joke last JK news we
actually did like worse jobs that people
didn't want or some [ __ ] and
veterinarian was one of them like it's
not what they expected [ __ ] no [ __ ]
you're just putting everyone yeah it's
just [ __ ] just murdering animals all
day you're killing everyone's favorite
cat everyone becomes a vet thinking that
one day they're gonna be out there
saving doctors like er animal version
and [ __ ] I mean saving [ __ ]
I don't want it anymore it's too
expensive and like you think it's gonna
be like this loving family I mean like
oh please do something and please
whatever it takes and then they're like
is this gonna cost money [ __ ] no just
kill it I don't care
you didn't go to college because of
entertainment
yeah oh yeah of course I was I well I
never planned I never planned on going
to college ever not even high school
[ __ ] no dude I barely got out of there
what got you to go [ __ ] College I'm
gonna go straight to where did you do
UCB yeah okay well that's kind of
college yeah well I got I got kind of a
weird job from going leaving high school
going into professional improv in San
Diego so like I was getting paid like
very little but like you're something
though or something so it gives you a
little bit of incentive and makes you
feel like you can be you know you could
be a Carney for life well there's that
there's that initial momentum right
where you're like oh this is actually
like doing something like I'm not just
like starving all the time for the sake
of starving all the time but your
parents don't understand and they think
it's really stupid especially improv
because it kind of is improv's really
[ __ ] if they ever showed one of your
classes and they're just like the [ __ ]
you skipped college for this yeah like
you're gonna get a suggestion yeah
you're not even doing the work because
the the hot the the height of the Improv
Tower is you get to be on whose lives in
anyway which only ran for like four
seasons they brought it back they
brought it back they brought it back
okay but there but that's what I mean
like where's it going it's a lot he's
like who the [ __ ] is gonna go and it's
like that's it it's Wayne Brady and the
one other guy the thing where you go but
yeah so yeah I went to Comedy school I
guess you could say but that's I didn't
go to call also coming from a generation
where like most of our parents have like
like real jobs yeah they're like wait
what do you want to do like I want to
make people laugh
[Laughter]
they're like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] brutal and it's not even like
stand-up comedy or like something that
has a career trajectory like that's
that's it it's that or like maybe SNL
Matt TV okay so hypothetically you're
going to college
you're going to be a [ __ ] geek in
college what else are you gonna do
you're gonna like sign up for a
fraternity you're gonna like I'm a plow
ass yeah you're gonna plow ass yeah I'm
gonna start beating them beating cheeks
up all over
yeah within your within your department
or I know yeah
they're all you gotta Wade through a
bunch of things I was like what is this
you're gonna really dig through I've
seen how he deals with women it's pretty
similar he just moved him aside yeah I'm
just a [ __ ] Assassin's Creed [ __ ]
waiting my way through the crowd would
you live on the dorms did you get an
apartment would you be in the frat house
bro I hated having roommates I hated it
do you guys still have roommates I don't
mean to I got a roommate damn sorry your
life sucks it does it sucks living with
20 year olds though just in general yeah
it's bad I also hate fraternities
I always judge them because I was like
you guys don't want to be gangsters
I like the ones we knew yeah they're
just losers most of the time most of the
time do you know because all the ones we
know they're like the Frat people yeah
no they're just [ __ ] party people I
just wanted to like get drunk you know
it was our generation though everybody
was a wannabe gangster like they're
throwing a [ __ ] like there were
wannabe gangsters in high school like I
saw that just KKK
yeah I'm like you better keep your
fingers down here
wait what was dancers like in college
the best squiggling man the [ __ ] best
uh other than other than if you really
if I were to just objectively explain it
you'd probably be like that sucks ass we
would literally there was no dance
studios for the street teams so we would
practice in the [ __ ]
parking structures and we would start
like 9 p.m we didn't know like 3 A.M on
average and it would be literally in a
[ __ ] parking structure and then
anytime a car would come by because they
had to park or some [ __ ] be a game off
everybody had to like split the road car
go by and park and then you come back on
with your boom
boxing how rehearsal would be
back then now now knowing what I know is
extremely inefficient but back then you
would go there you would have like
coordinated warm-ups you'd review the
routines that you learned you might
learn a new routine you spend like over
an hour cleaning you might work on a
transition trying to put together a
competitive show oh okay so you take
like three months to put together a
competitive show to compete but if I
were to redo it knowing what I do now I
[ __ ] put the whole show together in
less than a week because like why are
you wasting your time when you give
yourself three months to work on a
project right you actually suck the
whole way until maybe real start real
stuff starts happening last week anyway
yeah yeah right everything starts coming
together but why because you guys are
lazy college students and you guys
procrastinate I think it's just uh this
that was just the structure that I was
like taught going into a team when you
join a group of something you kind of
like fall to the system yeah but I feel
like you know and coming out of it now
if I were to just have the knowledge
that of what I had now I ended up
becoming the director I ended up
becoming a director of other dance
organizations I would run that [ __ ]
different versus is coming in just a
minute to the way it was done obviously
you gotta learn [ __ ] like traditional
stuff but it was [ __ ] inefficient you
know what I mean so you know what you do
now know now you would still go and
dance again
yeah I think I would have a great ass
well first because you just know so much
more about dance I honestly feel like
the joining a dance team in college 80
was the culture and the lifestyle 20 was
dancing you know none of it was girls
that's in the 80 percent
I'm trying to allude to that because
whenever I think about guys in college
like trying to build a skill whatever
they're doing I think they're going
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was the first half of my dance
Journey my first half of my dance
Journey was like yo I'm just trying to
like [ __ ] impress him I want her to
look at me second half of my dance
journey is when I started trying to
impress other dudes that were like
really good you just went the other way
is that when you transcend your hobby
into like actual like hard work is when
he was like now I need to impress other
I think plow and ass would have been a
uh a better a better priority what's up
you don't think you [ __ ] enough in
college nah nah are you in a
relationship relationship yeah I think
that was my biggest mistake the worst
being in a [ __ ] long-ass related
being in love you learn a lot you learn
a lot but when you realize like no
matter what every single one of us we're
to go back in time when was college for
us
like 2003 years ago now right yeah not
that far so we're looking at minimum 15
plus years ago it's like chances are
most of us might not have even been with
our significant others that we're with
now might not I don't know about Nick oh
Nick was Nick's the only ones
I went to a commuter School dudes were
you banging her in the dorms though I
didn't even go to dorms I don't even
know we're on the commute I don't even
know what a [ __ ] dorm looked like
dude where'd you go where'd you go dog
come on I went to uh CSUN oh nothing she
doesn't have dorms oh well I went to I
just commuted I drove there [ __ ] 30
minutes from Pasadena yeah it wasn't
that bad it's more of a commuter School
anyways yeah definitely most CAL States
are but but Cal State Northbridge was
cool because it had a really [ __ ] big
nice campus so I'd walk around over
there I'd be like this it is a nice game
they have a huge and nice Performing
Arts Center we throw a show there they
have nice gyms and [ __ ] over there they
have a really cool gym I never even been
there I should go ah you should
skip that up there you go why would you
want to go there but how would you redo
it
just not go dude not go not go that's
the entire message of this whole video
skip college kids yeah no I think I for
sure no look I learned a lot of cool
things in college I think I learned when
I went through my two years
at CSUN I realized like oh I really like
science that's what I realized yeah
like science I don't know I did I was
like this is dope as [ __ ] but the but
we'll be playing with like [ __ ] Petri
dishes yeah yeah dude [ __ ] beakers
and like I mean lab coats bubbling yeah
yeah yeah washing your eyes with the
[ __ ] sink thing yeah [ __ ] dude I had
all that nah but the problem was that I
had to go through so much nonsense
to get to the cool science stuff like I
was I was on David's podcast and I was
telling the story about how one of my
classes we had to learn how to juggle
what the [ __ ] it was a motor for science
yeah because it's a Kinesiology right
and look part of Kinesiology a big chunk
of it is like nonsense already though
it's [ __ ] stupid
it sounds legit dumb we had to learn how
to like learn skills and like understand
the basis of teaching skills to other
people that sounds amazing
this sounds freaking great dude that was
my final though dude I had to go into
the final and show the professor just me
and him in a [ __ ] clipboard and I had
a Juggle in front of him he's just being
lazy
everybody wants a [ __ ] easy final I
would win if somebody would explain to
me and say hey you're gonna either take
this class your final is juggling
or this class dude give me a test why do
you want life to be shittier no no no
because yeah would you put an A in that
class what are you gonna do with it I
did you go to clowns exactly I'm gonna
I'm gonna be I'm getting hot right now
because I'm mad I think it's more useful
right now than being able to write a
dissertation on mitochondria yeah that's
true but like learning how to juggle
three like cotton balls at one time
because that's what it felt like it was
really [ __ ] hard dude and I was like
I'm not gonna spend time
to go drive all the way to Northridge on
a Friday you're mad because you couldn't
do it dude oh I did it I I [ __ ] I did
it in front of him and I was like I'm
getting some [ __ ] ball I can't no I
can't juggle I can't juggle [ __ ]
prove that you ate this final you know
what's you know what's surreal right now
is I'm in the video where Nick is pissed
about juggling
that's why I [ __ ] hate clowns dude
I can't I can't I failed I well I I
didn't do my final prop but I didn't do
my final I showed them I I kept fumbling
it and I was like I looked at him like
yeah I didn't practice
no I was like upset he saw I was upset I
was like dude I'm not gonna juggle I was
like I didn't learn this and you put him
in a [ __ ] headlock my pitch for video
title is Nick's angry about juggling
that's the funniest part of it he's
getting eaten she wants to be pissed off
bro I had to pay money for this dog I
had to pay money to go to this [ __ ]
class and then sometimes I would show up
to class just for that class and we just
practice our skills in class I'm
juggling I was like I drove all the way
out here to [ __ ] practice juggling in
a classroom like this is what my
education is paying you are really
immature for your age because I took
this one class it was called
[ __ ] mental health or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] mental health or something
it was some [ __ ] [ __ ] class right
and we would start every class
um everyone laying on the floor with the
lights off for 10 minutes and obviously
I'm the one that [ __ ] knocks out and
we wake up and we [ __ ] evaluate oh
how much stress did you have this week
and what was your mindset at it's like
the most [ __ ] class that everyone
gets an A on
and I loved it because it was so [ __ ]
easy
breathe in a room exactly and we're just
talking about feelings and like oh how
do you feel about your class and like
what was your career going to happen
with them you guys call yourselves fun
as [ __ ] yeah it was one of those
elective class third grade classes in
college right now learning how to juggle
[ __ ] silent reading times dude Nick's
like I did get on a [ __ ] spiral
release slide come on Smiley slide my
teacher's got a [ __ ] clipboard I
gotta go all the way down the [ __ ]
thing in my shorts every day we had to
go into a ball pit and [ __ ] jump in
it
what the [ __ ] out of school is this it's
[ __ ] clown School dude so I'm on the
monkey bars but like my legs already
touching the bottom are you kidding me
the shortest monkey bars in the world
Steve's tall guy though I'm a tall guy I
never had fun on the monkey you were
just like standing why was that fun yeah
doing that [ __ ] thing that you do
because you're tall and you're like yeah
you think it's hilarious that you're
just walking across the monkey bars you
can only do that joke so many times
though completely sucks yeah attack
after like five minutes but that's why
you got to get new friends so you can do
it again oh yeah that's true cycle them
out how would you redo College I'm
already scared I um to be honest dude I
hacked my way through college like a
[ __ ] I don't think anyone here
is surprised dude
Joe winged it you're not a studious
studious student I got magna [ __ ] laude
dude so is that right yes [ __ ]
straight A's for three years straight
did you go to clown college too
I think I I think I really would have
challenged myself and and applied like
at maybe an Ivy League or something to
see what I what I could get into I
didn't do any of that because so I just
gamified everything so I was like okay
where are the community so it was like I
did the Community College to University
system right
um and then I looked at Rate My
Professor I strategized who the easiest
teachers that I can get an A with and
then I looked at
um how did you know just look at the
pictures like if they're busty chicks
oh okay
this professor haven't changed their
final exam for 10 years if you go in
this Library it's right there or
whatever yeah and um it was cool it was
it was right next to I had that in the
bookmarks that raped my professor and
rate my poo.com they were just like
right next to you rate my poo you know
that [ __ ] yeah so there was um all the
community colleges here right like they
weigh the same but one could be more
competitive like PCC like you had top
tier students there so then
if you wanted to transfer out to like a
good University it's way [ __ ] harder
to go from there so I was looking at
different places to go and I went right
here to elac and Bart showed me this
place called Trade Tech and Trade Tech
was [ __ ] cake bro and not a lot of
people transfer from that Community
these guys are slaying in community
colleges too yeah yeah check out Trey
Texas
we signed up I remember we were walking
to [ __ ] what was that the
administration right and it was a bum
with a bleeding scalp taking a [ __ ] yeah
and we're just like all right this is
college it's in the it's in the part of
La that looks like a like third world
country like there's a lot of parts in
L.A no this one
this [ __ ] was like a college in the
middle of skid row yeah this world was
[ __ ] just in the middle of the street
[ __ ] bleeding Scout for no reason
taking a [ __ ] and then me and Joe are
like dude we should probably get parking
permits because I think like parking
industry is not good and this other
homeless lady comes out and goes what
are you doing
and the guy's taking a [ __ ] he's like oh
hey I think I'm your professor
he's working on the lesson plan you guys
nailed it it was wild I love that that's
the equivalent of like you guys
basically were doing for your education
what everyone does with YouTube now it's
like I went to a one star review
restaurant okay let's see how it is oh I
can't believe it's shitty and then um I
wasn't even gonna go and continue
because I was I was just gonna I built a
business did all that stuff I had an
online uh business selling [ __ ]
diecast cars and at the last minute I
was like you know what I think I'm gonna
finish college and then Bob was like you
gotta apply for next year you're too
late and I was like what the [ __ ]
because then you don't have to you have
to apply a lot of parts just your
college counselor yeah he was dude yeah
you know you have to apply for like fall
for like the next year's cement or
whatever right so I was like I don't
want to wait like a [ __ ] whole half a
year until I get admitted so I just
looked at what schools around me would
probably let me in and I just went to
Cal State LA they got me in the week of
that's tight and then their
Administration was [ __ ] up because
while I was there I found out I didn't
even have enough credits to be there
nine days later your Magnum [ __ ] Laude
you didn't even have no credit
he's just the only guy who [ __ ]
showed up
literally dude and then so they I was
like I'm already in the [ __ ] system
all right you guys [ __ ] up and then
they're trying to tell me no you need to
go to this other place I was like let me
talk to someone that can help me they
were like it was worse than the DMV the
worst [ __ ] people working there right
and I was like look how about this I'll
just do the classes here and finish up
the credits I need to it's an easy fix
and then I had to go to a [ __ ]
counselor in the in a top person that
was like okay we'll do it this time but
not next I'm just negotiating with
Admissions and stuff like that and then
extorting them to be like you better
give me monthly [ __ ] laude before I give
you a bad review on Yelp [ __ ] what's
crazy is uh everyone knew like the hacks
and stuff so I remember in high school
everyone started going to Cal State to
the Health Center to get free condoms oh
that's right so somehow everyone knew
shortcuts to everywhere they would have
a giant bull like a [ __ ] high school
student okay yeah right there you can
get you'll come back with like a whole
lunch bag full of [ __ ] free condoms
geez that's a lot yeah it looks like a
whole lunch bag he ain't [ __ ] that
much sex is gonna be so boring tonight
oh yeah
because you're gonna put on every single
one
huge ass luck I remember those [ __ ]
paper lunch bag condoms yeah yeah I was
retired Joe did you give him my name
called loud speech
I have the [ __ ] certificate thing
with my name I have it like Magnum come
louder yes it's somewhere I don't know
where it is yeah I just love those
speeches man it's like it's like the
future a lot of us say that word but
what does it really mean
oh no I'm Never Gonna Leave
all the Places You'll Go oh I can't wait
to hear this [ __ ] Dr Seuss poem again
oh no I've already been here for two
hours and I had to park this is gonna be
awful
[Music]
foreign
[Music]